today we're checking out the brand new
iPhone se
[Music]
it looks so much like the iPhone 8 that
if I didn't know what the iPhone 8
looked like I wouldn't even know the
difference I happen to have an iPhone 8
here so you can see how it really does
look so similar the new se is a little
bit more white whereas this has a little
more of an eggshell type color the
iPhone name has been removed and the
logo is now centered and my iPhone 8
it's still running iOS 11 so the front
bezels on the new se the entire screen
is black so I kind of like this because
it looks very seamless so you can't tell
that there are edges around it it does
look like a full screen until you
actually turn it on whereas the 8 has
the white bezels to match the white
phone I'm not really sure which one I
prefer this looks better off but I also
like the white I don't know the iPhone
se comes in three different colors this
is the white it also comes in black and
a product red the starting price is 399
and that's actually a really incredible
price considering how powerful this
little phone is this is actually running
the a13 Bionic chip which is the same
chip that is in the iPhone 11 that's
gonna have an amazing impact on the
performance of this phone the original
se had a starting price also of 399 and
that was in 2016 so Apple is keeping
that same price yet giving it that a 13
buy on a chip that is in their highest
and lineup right now this is 1.4 times
faster than the original se and it also
will give you a four times graphics
boost the display is a 4.7 inch HD front
no display and what's great about this
is this is the same size as the iPhone 8
so all of the cases that you may already
have for the iPhone 8 or that are out
there already will work with a new SE
this also has touch ID and that's the
thing that I never thought that I would
really want back until I started having
to wear facemasks every time I go
outside or basically do anything cuz
guess what doesn't work when you're
wearing a face mask face ID it's also
weird I kind of missed having a home
button like just the haptic feedback on
this alone is it's just so satisfying
like I've definitely missed that the one
thing was very excited about though is
this does have wireless charging a lot
of times when companies are trying to
cut costs with our devices that's the
first thing that goes
so the fact that this does have wireless
charging is pretty exciting
so the camera is pretty impressive
you're still gonna be getting 4k 34 K 60
from this rear camera this is a 12
megapixel camera the front is a 7
megapixel selfie camera through these
also features a cinematic video
stabilization so even if you are
shooting at 1080 that extra
stabilization will help you shoot way
better front-facing videos it's pretty
stable actually you can do all of the
things that you normally would be able
to do on the higher-end phones like
slow-mo time-lapses it even has the
quick take video which I always forget
about so if you hold this down and then
swipe this will automatically start
recording a video I don't know why I can
never remember that that's a thing what
it is I shoot a lot of these videos and
just mono audio so when I am shooting
something in stereo it's always crazy to
hear the difference so I'm gonna shoot a
quick video here alright we're testing
out the video right now I'm shooting in
4k so you guys can see the stereo audio
so maybe if I go over here I'm over here
and if I go over here I'm over here I
wonder if the next iPhone will record in
360 reality audio I know that's like a
Sony property but these do have so many
lenses in them so anything is possible
the one thing that I would miss with
this is having that ultra wide lens this
does only have the wide-angle lens
there's no telephoto it will shoot
portrait mode though on the front and
back facing camera the newer iPhone 11
pros do shoot pet portrait mode this
will not since does really only have
this one lens this version of portrait
mode is mostly relying on software but
it's still pretty good and the fact that
this phone can do that is thanks to that
a 13 Bionic chip because it's doing so
many processes so quickly that it's able
to give you some pretty incredible
features so this comes in three storage
configurations there's a 64 or 128 and a
256 but what's really impressive is the
64 and the 128 there's only a $50
difference so if you are looking to do a
slight upgrade I would recommend just
going with the 128 because you really do
never know when you're gonna fill up the
storage on your phone but all that being
said a lot of stuff can be stored at the
cloud can offload apps you can keep all
of that stored virtually so if you do
opt for the 64 you will be perfectly
fine oh I also have one of the new
silicone cases
I've had moment cases on my other iPhone
for so long and I forgot how great these
cases are before I put this case I'll
know I want to show you guys a
comparison of this new SC lineup next to
every other white iPhone that I could
find that i have previously owned and
unfortunately one of the forms that i
don't have is an original IC let's take
a look
it's always so shocking how beautiful
this iPhone is without a case here they
are side by side I still love the
frosted glass of the 11 so pretty you
can see what's green to mr. tweeny
lookin bro Max and the SU let's put
these cases back on I can't be trusted
I'm gonna put that case on the iPhone 8
just to show you I'm gonna prove to
myself that it works here's the 8 same
phone same size it's not I do a quick
little photo and video test like I
always do after my unboxings we are
outside in our typical quarantine
fashion slippers in the backyard doesn't
matter it doesn't but we're gonna test
out some video some photos to show you
guys what this little guy can do we're
gonna start with front facing camera
first hi it's just being in the backyard
I've been outside in over a month
so obviously feelin and my intent test
if Maddie isn't here today he's with my
sister so guys are not gonna be getting
any quality Maddy content today I'm
purposely trying to move around a lot
to see how the cinematic stabilization
works so like I mentioned you can take
portrait photos on the front and the
back so let's just take a regular photo
first
[Music]
okay let's switch to portrait
this is all the lighting effects that
you guys are used to and have seen
before you could also adjust the f-stop
which will adjust how blurred or not
blur that background is so obviously one
of the highlights of the iPhone 11 pro
is you can do slow fees a slow-mo on the
front-facing camera this does not do
that but I think you guys will be okay
without having slow fees on your
front-facing camera but we can do 240
and 120 on the rear-facing camera which
i think is pretty good
I can't run very fast cuz my slippers
aren't on properly
[Music]
it wouldn't be a slo-mo test without
hair flips
[Music]
now take a few photos from the back
facing camera
[Music]
for K 30 let's test you out man my lawn
needs mold
this grass is growing it's getting so
long out here fake grass but Jenna
always tells me that and for some reason
I'm always like it's not this is the
back facing camera we should be in 4k 30
it's really cool though because this
will actually shoot up to fourth a 60 so
you can still get 4k and slow down the
60 to get some nice cinematic slow-mo so
let's try that out now
this is really bad this is a bad demo
[Music]
good thing it's water-resistant why is
this foaming what is happening I didn't
like that
why does my hose selling spaceship
I do plan on doing a way more extensive
tests with some moment lenses make sure
you I subscribe and hit the bell so
you'll be notified when I post that
video but I'm really excited about that
because I really want to try to push
this thing to its limits thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this first little look at the
new iPhone se I think this is an
incredible phone at such an incredible
price it's got all the photo and video
capabilities it's fast enough to play
all of the games that you would need to
play obviously it doesn't have the three
camera setup it won't do night mode but
if you're looking for a fast phone to
create some content stay connected with
your friends and family and do whatever
else it is that you're gonna be doing on
your phone this is the phone for you
[Music]